oh you loose warming it up okay so let's
get the air out dude why don't you just
buy the mr. crazy like that
well I obviously spent so much on the
outfit that I think it's irresponsible
to also subscribe to an entire app okay
alright so you're just gonna watch me
yes so you watch the video on the app
I'll watch you it's like a game of
telephone but with our bodies okay
all right are you ready to move with mr.
Crazy Legs
Yas whoa okay frog jump kicks here we go
all right they're moving into Jerusalem
really trying to mimic the instructor
good I'm mimicking you and that's how
this works right love it
dude I love the way your ponytail whips
yeah hmm I wish you could just go
topless and just wherever all the time
dude like I don't like this commentary
sorry okay here we go
raised camel work I say from the side I
don't understand a form with a block
lugging so it's like you're you're up
and then you drink you're up and then
the camel drink Wow okay geez you stick
your butt out like that in your chest oh
yeah and then you really use your core
and then you spread the bone the bone
rhythm
like I get it
you got that a killer yeah got it got it
good do you need me to move closer I got
to see the back a little more well it's
just like right left you know yeah and
so you should feel it in your core I've
done this box okay all right